[Inaudible].
Argentina. Yup. Yup. Argentina, once again is in the spotlight. Honestly,
I give you my word.
It's not that we here at visual politic habit and for this country,
or even particularly mean to focus on it, but what can we see?
Argentina is the country that during the first half of the 20th century was the
great Latin American superpower.
It just keeps on giving us bad news to talk about. For example,
relatively recently,
we told you here on this channel about the habit being rocked by the world's
longest warranty at the time of making this video,
even though it was no longer quite so strict,
Argentines have been in confinement or restricted activity for more than 250
days. As you can imagine, this is something that is setting the economy,
heart and economy that already had been having a lot of problems,
even by Argentinian standards since 2018.
So you could say that the Corona virus has been something like the nail in the
coffin, a very hard blue that is already having many consequences.
In particular.
One of them is a wave of companies that are seriously considering leaving
Argentina. Even though this could incur great financial losses,
of course weighing up the situation.
Many are thinking the staying could be much worse,
but what companies are we referring to and why are they considering leaving
Argentina? Why exactly is the current situation in this troubled country?
And this video, we're going to give you all the details. But before we do,
I just want to remind you of our new channel visual Academy, March.
The end of the Holy Roman empire is made from the whole team here at visual
politic. I'm going to cover some of the most interesting people,
places and periods in history.
Do you want to know more of a Gangas can of course you do well by the ancient
Greeks, obviously they're pretty cool.
And the invented democracy and my personal favorite,
you can find out all about the Vikings. It's got amazing animation,
fantastic storytelling, and some voiceovers that you might recognize.
So check out visual Academy here on YouTube and know all that.
Potential power.
And my friends.
Every time we talk about Argentina is almost impossible for us to not be
surprised by its perpetual,
inability to escape from what we can know openly call the problem of the
permanent crisis. After all, if we think about it,
clinically Argentina is a country with enormous potential,
a qualified population, plenty of cultural activity, a reasonably good climate,
a lot of natural resources, a large territory, et cetera, et cetera.
The list of positive attributes is very long.
And of course this observation is not unique to us,
nor are we the first ones to bring it to life
Way back in the 1960s, eventual Nobel prize winner.
Simon Kuznets stated that there were four types of countries according to their
economic performance,
the developed the underdeveloped Argentina and the
economic evolution of the countries that were in the first two groups could be
explained without many problems, but in the case of Japan and Argentina,
their evolution was exactly the opposite of what could be expected,
Japan for the better and Argentina for the worse,
another Nobel prize winner in economics.
Paul Samuelson described Argentina situation in 1980 in this way,
less than half.
If someone had asked me in 1945,
what part of the world do you expect to experience the most dramatic economic
takeoff in the next three decades?
I would probably give a similar answer to the one below Argentina is the wave of
the future. It has a temperate climate,
its population density offers a favorable endowment of natural resources per
employee by historical accident.
Its current population constitutes the most homogenous progeny of the nations of
Western Europe and the Argentina of 1945 is that intermediate state of
development from which one can easily expect rapid growth. Paul Samuelson
[inaudible] exterior volume, 30 number eight, Mexico, August,
1980 pages eight 21 to eight 29.
So I don't think we're going too far.
If we define Argentina as a lost opportunity and not just once,
but several times,
For example, during the last 30 years,
the world has experienced economic growth as never seen before. However,
Argentina has been underperforming since the 1940s,
since the imagines of Dwan Domingo, Peron,
they keep applying practically the same policies and getting the same results.
This is something we have already covered in several videos here on visual
politic. In fact, since the advent of democracy in 1983,
Argentina has been ruled by Peronism for 25 of the last 37 years.
And if we only focus on the province of windows eddies,
which is the largest and most populated in the country for 29 of those 37 years,
Peruna ism has ruined that is almost 80% of the time to make matters worse.
The rest of the leaders have not destined themselves much from policies that we
can almost consider typical for Argentina. There is Argentinian as Mara Donna.
Well, the point is that no,
in 2022 elements have come together that are capable of making even the hardiest
investor nervous, the Corona virus and a new government.
You see my friends on the 10th of December, 2019,
Alberto Fernandez took over the presidency,
although it's not clear exactly how far has power extends and how far the,
of his vice-president, the powerful Ms. Christina Fernandez. The Kitchener does.
[Inaudible].
In all fairness,
Alberto Fernandez came to the presidency of a badly damaged country under very
precarious conditions because if the legacy that Maricio McCree received in his
day was not exactly great.
So the one he left behind certainly doesn't have anything to envy.
We have covered this topic in detail,
in a previous video here on visual politic high unemployment,
high public spending,
high inflation and a considerable drop in the central banks reserves practically
all the indicators were very, very red.
And to top it all off two months after he came to office,
the Corona virus crisis Brocade turning the global upside down and leaving
Argentina, almost like a desert,
the most conservative forecasts point to a 12% fall in GDP in 2020,
an unemployment rate above 22% poverty rate,
close to 45% and inflation that could exceed the 50% barrier. In other words,
we could be talking about an economic tsunami rather than a perfect storm.
And remember,
this is taking place in a country that has been going from bad to worse since
2012, we've already mentioned the baggage received from previous governments,
but the truth is the policies is the current government could make things even
worse. Listen up.
Turning their backs on the world.
And Argentinian government has a unique plan to get out of the crisis.
A plan as unique as,
as peculiar and so far as it involves doing the opposite of what most countries
that have gone through a crisis have done in order to get out of it.
So do you want some examples? Well,
let's take a look at two of president Oberto Fernandez policies that have the
most impact on the Argentinian economy. First of all,
we have the exchange controls.
You see the Argentine government uses money as humans.
This is particularly known as the money-making machine to finance a large part
of public expenditure.
This is something that the Argentine government has been doing for decades to
the point that the value of their local currency has practically disappeared.
This is the cause of the enormous inflation that year after year plagues the
country,
and also explains why Argentines always jumped at the chance to switch to the
dollar. Yes,
when [inaudible] is one of those places where you can get discounts,
if you pay and foreign currency
And an effort to stop the collapse of the peso,
the government applies exchange controls this way.
If you want to buy dollars in the official market about 80 pesos per dollar,
you will have to meet a series of requirements, which is usually difficult.
That's why the alternative is the black market where the dollar doesn't trade
ATP. So it was around 145. In addition, if you're a company that exports,
the government will take away the dollars you receive and change them into
pesos, the official exchange rate about 80 pesos. But of course,
if you want to buy dollars again, for example,
to pay for imports and you can't get them on the official market,
you have to get them on the black market at 145 pesos.
Each that's a loss of almost 40%. In addition, foreign companies have a very,
very difficult time getting their hands on any benefits,
reaped from the country.
So you see that things aren't easy for Argentina exporters,
or at least I personally would not like to be one of them.
And then we have the labor regime, which was already costly in Argentina,
but during the pandemic, as even prohibited layoffs,
as illustrated in this quote from Alberto Fernandez.
As I said at the [inaudible], no one is saved alone. You have to be supportive,
put yourself in the other shoes and help them.
Some miserable people forget those who work for them. And in the crisis,
they fire them to those wretches Pope Francis spoke.
Now I tell them that I will not let them do it. Oberto Fernandez on Twitter.
All sound pretty good, but usually reality is a little bit different.
Imagine that you have a company right now because of the pandemic has low sales
or even no sales.
If you can't make stopping adjustments or resort to strategies to reduce losses,
even temporarily,
then the whole company may end up closing dime and all the workers will be out
on the streets. Reality is sometimes unpleasant,
but if you turn your back on it, you might have a problem. In any case,
Fernandez messages don't seem to be the best for encouraging investment in the
country, but that's not all,
it's not just the current crisis the country is going through.
And the kind of policies that have been put in place so far in 2020,
if we also add those that were already in place, such as Argentina,
being in the top three countries in the world for imposing the highest taxes on
businesses.
And we can already understand why many companies are starting to consider
fleeing or at least stopping any investment altogether. In fact,
according to a UN report, even before the Corona virus,
Argentina was the second country on the list for the worst evolution of foreign
direct investment so far in the 21st century.
Imagine their ranking now and take note because it's not just a boat.
Companies.
According to us.
Survey conducted by the consulting firm to and research strategy and association
with the company's inclusion. And Guesty on our patio.
I have 10 Argentinians were able to weigh up what their situation will be like
in 10 years with leave the country if they have the conditions to do so.
The bottom lane is the Argentinians with the capacity to think about the long
term or thinking about.
We've been on the other hand.
In September,
the financial times published a report in which it proposes the exit of a
growing number of foreign companies from the country. For example,
the Buenos Aires correspondent of this newspaper told her at the same time that
the minister of economy Martin Guzman was presenting the 2021 budget with
relatively optimistic projections,
but Chilean department store company file Bella, uh,
noticed his progressive exit from Argentina.
It will start with the immediate closure of four of the 19 stores they have in
the country while they look up buyer for the rest of the operations.
But having said that, I'm sure many of you are thinking, but wait a minute,
grunt, isn't this an isolated case, something specific,
are there really more companies who want to bail out in a market of 45 million
people? Well, yeah,
the truth is that there are more and more companies are starting to propose this
strategy. This is the case with airlines. For example, in June,
the Chilean airline,
LATAN confirmed this departure from the country and began to negotiate with its
1,700 employees. It happened in Argentina for 15 years,
maintain flights to 12 local destinations and held a 16% market
LATAN was followed by air New Zealand,
which has confirmed that even one's normal air travel is restored.
It will no longer provide connecting services between New Zealand on the land of
tango. Exactly the same news was announced by Qatar airways in August Emirates,
an instant suspension of its operations for an indefinite period.
A Norwegian airlines has sold its domestic operations.
In the company.
Obviously a lot of airlines are having some trouble with the Corona virus,
but it's not just the airlines and fire Bella.
Many other companies from very different sectors are considering following the
same steps. Of course,
most of them are very cautious because they obviously want to reduce the
conflict. And at the same time, try to sell their businesses.
You see that Chilean are leaving because.
There was a clear anti market anti-business bias.
So it is worrisome that Alberto Fernandez administration continues in that line.
One CTO, president of the Confederation for production and consumption.
Between 1919, 2016.
Chile has certainly been the second largest investor in Argentina, after Brazil.
In any case,
some companies have already announced their intentions that is they're going to
leave or at least reduce their presence considerably.
Do you want to know which ones then let's start with a list.
[Inaudible].
German chemical company bus has announced the transfer of a large part of his
operations to Brazil. The same as being done by the French company, Sango bane,
which has moved its windshield production to Brazil and has closed its factory
and the town of component in the province of winter Saudis.
During the month of July, the French laboratory company,
Pierre Fabry sold his installations and concluded his activity in the country.
The same was done by the German packaging and pharmaceutical supplies company.
[Inaudible].
This was on Ray star, a manufacturer of cell phones for brands,
such as Samsung and LG as a plant in Rio grenade with 500 employees has
finalized the sale of his production facilities in the country in exchange for
the symbolic figure of $1. Let's just say,
but their priority was to leave at any price for S part a bedroom company. Nike,
I noticed that at the beginning of the year that it was transferring us
operations and the country, along with those in Brazil, Chile,
and Uruguay to the Mexican company axle,
then there's also the North American giant Walmart that has 92 establishments
distributed in 21 provinces and the employees more than 10,000 people,
they have also confirmed that they are seeking to leave completely.
They're looking for a buyer for its Argentina activities.
Everything indicates an addition to those companies.
We have mentioned companies such as soda,
muck burger King and Starbucks would also leave Argentina.
If they phoned someone to take over their business,
You see my friends, this trend seems to be the last stage of a long process.
I seen Argentina become a country allergic to foreign investment to put this in
perspective,
the land of tango has gone from representing around 20% of all foreign
investment coming into Latin America to less than 5%.
Obviously any foreign company leaving the country as bad news,
large international groups have a greater capacity to invest more.
Know-how more modern management systems and usually more technology at the same
time,
the great economic success stories of the world and their success by attracting
investment. And in many other places, we find new stories like this one.
A Swiss Canton will soon surpass Hong Kong is the best tax Haven in the world
for companies.
Hong Kong will soon lose its status as the place with the lowest corporate tax
in the world and will be replaced by the small mountainous Canton of [inaudible]
in Switzerland,
Bloomberg Greece to offer a 50% tax break for returning professionals
and digital migrants writers.
The case of Argentina is unique because this country aspires to get endless
crisis by doing exactly the opposite by scaring off foreign investment,
imposing more taxes, more currency exchange controls, and much,
much more regulation, perhaps that is precisely why as an eternal crisis.
What do you think at this point?
It's your turn to tell us what future do you think awaits Argentina will that
manage to overcome the current crisis?
Does it really matter to all these big companies are leaving?
And if you are watching us from that country, as we know, many of you are,
how do you rate our bear tool, Fernandez management?
What do you think he should change?
Leave your answer in the comments below as always.
We really hope you enjoyed this video. Please hit the link if you did.
And don't forget to subscribe for brand new videos. Also,
don't forget to check out our friends at the reconsidered media podcast.
They provided the vocals in this episodes that were not my dulcet twins.
Finally,
this channel is supported by cause of Patrion and our patrons on that platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting our mission of providing independent
political coverage. And as always, I'll see you then.
And if you want to learn more about politics and hear even more of my lovely
voice, you can join us at reconsider media.
We have a podcast@reconsidermedia.com slash podcast. See you there.